this is the Warriors they're the best
franchise in how many decades really
winning like they're winning right now
he's unprecedented the way they're
playing
Kevon for you we want you back at any
contract you would like
[Applause]
katie is willing to take that it is
reported that he's going to take a
little bit less they'll be waving again
next summer
if he goes short-term where do the
Warriors go long-term
I just coming in and go to work and try
to get better as a player everyday and
tell my teammates of Elektra prostitute
I just thought every one of those plays
where I could show a little bit more
emotion than I usually show I was
talking heads who say it better without
us just ludicrous like that's crazy
this is the best play in the world you
could put him on the 30th best team
League and that's that team will make
the playoffs that's how talented he is
just trying to see how it could be
perfect at the time down I know that's
impossible but if I strive towards it
you know I give myself the goal to reach
I'm just trying to keep getting better
to apply finals in a row and this team
right now is exhausting kevin was
getting on to Ramon for now passing the
ball and tram on took exception
sometimes it can get a bit overwhelming
it's gonna get worse before it gets
better
sometimes all along with this do I do
draymond Green just went off he brought
up Kevin Durant's contract started
cussing him out
draymond Green said to Kevin Durant
essentially you got one foot in one foot
out you're not down with this team's
weight you know the Weig the rest of us
off and that's where it really didn't
belong the warrior is suspending
draymond Green and fighting him what was
that was so bad that all the team on the
side of that Hey he needs to be
suspended he disrespected Katie their
relationship won't be the same that
Kevin have you and Ramon been able to
hash anything else no I'm never gonna
change who I am the B word is something
that everybody's been using draymond
Green has said that to a lot of you he
said that to his own teammates before he
certainly said that the Kevin Devine can
you break through that mental fatigue
for three periods
Tina's benefit on that third year it's
not about skillset it's about metal 14
gonna come here every day
actually about free agency X might
animes on coaches and rile up the fans
about it let us play basketball
he just has to take his time and put
those past games behind him and move
forward like I said we know the formula
to success for us as a group but you
know trying to get up every night to be
dominant that's a tough thing mentally
once we dive deep into basketball then
the the roamers and everything that
swirls around the team no really don't
mean so much you just don't want to play
around with the Clippers they have some
guys that could go off
[Applause]
they both had just thrown out
you know I want to have a little
back and forth with patrick beverley I'm
Kevin Durant no way ever told to bear
you want the wolf
if you want the wolf you get everything
that comes along with it right-center
yesterday's Kevin Durant showed
everybody who Kevin Durant is you talk
about locked in when they come on tour
like this nobody can read there's nobody
that can shoot this guy three different
shots I think they'll see the Warriors
that they're tough I think they know
what's at stake I'm either he's Kevin
Durant
I promise me try sometimes you come
across special people and it doesn't
matter what you send so he showed it
tonight you put them guys on his
shoulders things like I'm Kevin Durant
God Know Who I am
that's a bold statement to make means
you about to go see some guys that's
extremely competitive that was one of
the great performances never seen in my
life
you know he's the ultimate weapon
because there's no defense for Kevin
come in and go to work every day cause
no problems there's nobody that can
limit this guy except himself
Wow I don't think he knows what he did
and he thought someone hit him in the
Achille I don't know the extent of his
injury but that's never fun man he's one
of the best to ever do it I want to try
to win this for him we miss him I'm
gonna miss him man it's not the same you
out there without him
take doctor's choice of direction
no Kevin Durant is not playing but yes
his presence is constantly being felt
how about one of the best to ever play
the game Kevin Durant moving you out to
the floor
for the last tune for the NBA title
three here in
but Toronto Raptors
from an NBA title you've got one last
hope and that hope is Kevin Durant and
this was the day he targeted his team
has put them in position to make history
not only will he start but according to
Steve Kerr Kevin Durant will not have
any minute
whatsoever
hurry to the ran there's his first shot
rattles over three
[Music]
- four - is Kevin Duran Duran treachery
Kevin Durant is
with the rat not to the way
[Music]
the expectation is that this will be a
torn Achilles tendon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trying to place health in line to come
back and compete at the highest level
he's one of the best to ever do it the
feeling the last couple months before
the injury was Kevin's probably gonna
live then he comes back and he gets
injured and you go or whether it changes
the whole dynamic well I know how good I
am and I know the demand on my skills in
the lead Kevin Durant decision to leave
the Thunder for the two-time defending
Western Conference champs in Golden
State getting up banned laser-focused
but if you don't think that this guy is
as good as anybody have never been able
to in the league you weren't watching
what we just saw Kevin Durant has to be
aggressive at the same time he's part of
a great team and play a team game when
everybody touches the basketball we good
shape
[Music]
baby has officially declined his player
option with the Warriors he's going to
be rehabbing this is a thirty-eight
million dollar redshirt year for Kevin
Durant wherever he signs there's no
question that the New York is felt that
thing push away from them and toward
Brooklyn and Brooklyn's a great position
here it get a commitment from Kyrie
Irving and then use that the pursuit KD
what would it mean if Durant chooses the
Nets
if I had to bet which team I think it'd
be on next year it will be the Nixon
Kevin Durant should not go to New York
by himself
if the Warriors on the
looking at Maxie's
[Music]